Jeanne d'Albret uh good morning I'm
justifying yawn right nice to meet you I
know it's early and I'm the first stock
so this is gonna have to be very very
energetic the good news is that I work
with kids so I'm used to be very
energetic today I'm gonna talk about
reading writing and tinkering with AI my
name is Stephanie and Ruka I'm a recent
graduate from MIT Media Lab personal
robots group and my research is about AI
education for children so before before
jumping into that why do I say read and
write many of you might recognize some
of these titles how many of you have
read at least one of these books have
heard about them okay Lynn that was to
be expected so the first book here
actually this term of reading and
writing was coined by Lawrence Lessig
who's also one of the fathers of
creative comments these open licenses
were using for sharing code and in this
book the remix manifesto he talks about
the importance of not only reading the
web but also writing the web and moving
those ideas forward in this book that is
called democratizing innovation which is
actually available online that you can
read it it's available for free Eric von
Hippel also makes an argument about why
it is important to allow people to read
and write the web and code and he talks
about open source and I guess that if
you're here at PI data many of you know
why it is important to share code and
data and why it is important to faster
open-source communities but Eric when
people actually makes an argument that
people not don't do this only for
altruistic reasons they do it because
it's actually the best way to solve
complex problems right and if you
democratize if you share your tools if
you share your knowledge people will use
it in ways that you do not expect and if
we take that from the digital domain
from code to physical things in this
book by Cory Doctorow which is also
available online and you can download
today and check it out it's a really
good book he talks about how that works
how does reading and writing how does
tinkering apply to the physical world
right so what happens when we can read
and write not only code but also devices
controllers anything from your Arduino
and Raspberry Pi to an old phone or what
have you so this is the context in which
my work has been developed in this
culture of democratizing who can access
ideas and build good ideas and how do we
keep keep ourselves ourselves in check
with our work by making it publicly
available in a way that it can be used
remixed and repurpose by many other
people so from the digital age in today
we actually have an entire generation of
kids that are growing up not only with
code and digital applications but also
with AI I know in Europe it's we're not
quite there yet but in the u.s. we
actually have more than 47 million
people who have an Alexa at home how
many of you have heard about Alexa okay
more hands yeah you're awake so you know
these devices were made by big corporate
Amazon with the main purpose of selling
us things but they are presenting
presented as this intelligent home
assistant that can answer any question
and here's the crux they were not
designed for kids but we have an entire
generation of kids that are growing up
with this technology and just like we
grew up with internet and we take for
granted the fact that we could do a
single search from our phone from our
pocket these kids are going to take for
granted the fact that you can just talk
to everything and ask a question and get
an answer so that's going to completely
change how these kids perceive
technology learn with and from
technology but also how they talk to
their parents how they talk to their
friends right so I've been working with
kids for a long time I'm going to date
my
now but basically in 2012 I've been
working with kids for more than 10 years
in 2012 I started this organization
called hack edenia where the idea was to
learn by doing science and technology
and hack with kids academia so I got a
lot of articles where he's like she's
doing a school of hackers yes I'm doing
the school of hackers and that's not
crackers the difference is quite
important so we were doing these
workshops with kids all over the world
and training local mentors like yourself
to work with kids and then we did a
project that was funded on IndieGoGo in
Africa in 10 African countries where
local communities would pick a
challenging the in in their town or in
their village and say okay we want to
build a prototype to improve the way we
access energy or improve the way we
filter water and then they would
prototype and learn how to do that and
then teach you to kids but then you
would say like what do we do if we don't
have like a local maker space or hacker
space or even a library and that's when
we start doing this camps in shipping
containers so the idea there was like if
you don't have a space an invention lab
where you can start building and
prototyping we're going to build one for
very for very cheap actually for free
the first one we did in Berlin we were
able to get a shipping container from a
recycling company and all all the tools
donated and have a lot of people we put
it right next to the Berlin Wall and
have a lot of people coming in and
starting to hack and then we could move
the container and even ship it somewhere
so this is the type of work I've been
doing before and I should say that I
come from here so for me it is very
important I am roaming a Romanian which
is not that far from Poland although I
live in us now and I come from a small
village called manechan Goodin which is
here in the Carpathian Mountains so when
I grew up I did not know that all of
these things exist like I did not know
that I can solder or program or build
robots and he took me a very long time
to reach to a place where I could even
know that these things exist so I can
learn about them and that really
motivated me because I real
is that what differentiates us is not
only how smart we are and how hard we
work it's also what opportunities we
have access to and once the fact that
you're here means you already are you
have a lot of opportunities right so
once you have access to those
opportunities it kind of comes with this
responsibility of sharing back so when I
grew up and I learn like oh my god you
know I can do synthetic biology and I
can learn about nanotechnology like and
I couldn't help thinking imagine if I
would have learned about this when I was
six when I was seven how much more I
could have done and that's what
motivated me to start hacky dinya and
then I would meet girls like this girl
is six this was in Berlin like long time
ago this is 2013 who was soldering at
six right in a normal school we would
not allow a girl at six years old to
solder because it's too dangerous and
she might get burned right so we are
trying to change the educational system
and the way we teach with people who are
products of the same system who think
that we should separate kids by age and
we should differentiate what they can
learn at six what they can learn at
seven what they can learn at eight and
I'm gonna tell you that that's purely
false right who are we to decide when
and how a child should learn something
if they're curious this is a living
proof that this girl you know like her
parents two days later they call me
where can we buy a soldering iron like
she was at this for two hours
she wouldn't even make up take a break
to take her to drink water right so I
think what I'm trying to say here is
that learning happens everywhere and
learning is not tied to institutions and
it's not tied to diplomas and it's not
tied to titles and all of that it is
actually a thing that happens in
community it's a thing that needs to be
playful needs to be experimental and it
needs to be fun right like that's one of
the key things that I learn from kids we
explore and discover the most amazing
things when we're having fun
and when we're playing so taking this
from the maker education the science
education the coding education and
thinking how do we bring that into the
future because like I told you it's not
up to us what the future of AI ethics
and AI applications and it's actually up
up to our kids how do we prepare them
for this future that they're growing up
with so when I start to look into this I
discovered that there were these two
devices I don't know how many of you
have seen this creepy doll or this other
device over here or know what they are
yeah go ahead
can you tell us this is Aris total very
good so this is this was Mattel you know
Mattel is one of the largest
manufacturers of toys
this was Mattel's attempt at creating an
Alexa for kids it was supposed to be
launched last year for Christmas and
they didn't do any research to see how
kids interact with AI how they perceive
it how they trust it and they just said
we're gonna put an entire division
invest a lot of resources and create a
AI for kids that has a camera you can
put it in the nursing room it can track
your kid everywhere and we're gonna
launch it for Christmas so you can put
it under the Christmas tree and guess
what 15,000 parents signed the petition
and they were like hell no never before
the corporation was able to store so
much information about our kids why
would we let you into the nursing room
you didn't even ask us if we're okay
with this or not so there was a huge
backlash and we see this over and over
again with Hello Barbie huge backlash
but these like toys manufacturing
companies and even all the big companies
I I don't think they're learning from
this lessons right so they had to pull
out this this was never launched in the
end they had to pull out this this
product and then this doll it's called
my friend Kayla it's a Bluetooth
connected doll and it was hacked five
days after it was released in Europe so
it's currently banned in Germany you
cannot buy it
because it's not a secure device for
your kids but in u.s. you can still get
it on Amazon it's only $29 right so this
is not really like the face like of
Armageddon at all and I'm not saying
that we shouldn't have connected devices
for kids because that is the future I'm
just saying that we need a lot of
research and much better policies and
much better regulation for how these
devices should be designed and how they
should be put on the market so when I
started to look into it like two years
ago there were no papers about how kids
are interacting with current AI devices
and we've done a pilot study with 26
families we brought 26 families at Media
Lab into the lab and we put different
stations where they could interact with
Amazon Alexa with the my friend Kayla I
would cause more with Google home and
after they were playing with these
devices and their parents were playing
with these devices we asked them is it
smart is it smarter than you is it
friendly do you trust it and we found
quite a few interesting things first of
all there was a big difference in age
like smaller kids three and a half to
six why are you so sure that the devices
are smarter than they are all the older
kids from six to ten were saying yeah
alex is smarter than I am and I'm like
how can it be smarter you ask questions
that it couldn't answer is like yeah but
it has so much information it's smarter
than I am through me I was like wow
there's something here how are these
kids positioning themselves in front of
this technology right and clearly it has
something to do with going to school
where intelligence means regurgitating
definition that you were taught right
but I also think it has to do with
demystifying how we market and present
like this intelligent devices and
intelligent toys so let me show you a
quick video to see how kids were playing
with these devices and let's hope that
the sound is gonna work
today's children are growing up with
social intelligent and relational
devices found
in their homes and their schools my
colleague Randy we do study together
what do children think about machines
that think to engage this question we
ran a study where 27 children between
the ages of 3 and 10 interacted with
different devices they played games just
called small they asked the question
[Music]
then we ask is it smarter than you is it
like a friend does it have feelings we
[Music]
saw the children and prop amorphized AI
in playful ways the voice of language
determine how intelligent and playful
the AI seemed but Julie was like a
normal person she sounded like a normal
person he was a tough morning the Sheep
it felt like she actually understood
that I said we both so I'm just gonna do
the final think about our own nature hey
he's your best friend
and before the pit but if I had you I
think you so it's endearing but oh my
god like really can you imagine like if
you tell a child who's like 5 or 6
I'm your best friend that child you
believe you right or if you replace a
Google search with a box that will tell
you the same first result but with a
friendly voice we're not gonna question
it in the same way right and this is
what we're doing right now so because I
told you that I was very intrigued by
the fact that they said Alexa is so much
smarter than they are
I decided to do another study and really
investigate more what do kids mean when
they say smart maybe the way they say
smart about machines is different from
the way they say smart about people
right and we had a study where we
invited 30 families and basically they
would watch videos of a mouse solving a
maze and then they would watch videos of
a robot solving a maze and then they had
to solve a maze by telling a robot so
the reason we did this is because we
wanted them to compare like animal
intelligence with robot intelligence and
with themselves and the kids and the
parents participated in the study
separately and it was very interesting
because here you can see like a child
solving a maze and the parent solving a
maze and he was very interesting because
we actually saw that all their children
with mirror would have the same choices
that their parents did more more than
the young kids so not only that they
would choose like oh the mouse was
smarter or the robot was martyred the
same way their parents did but even the
language they used to explain why the
robot was smart they would say oh the
robot was smart because it was
programmed or the robot was stupid
because it was programmed right and then
they would explain oh it has sensors and
it has a map or oh the mouse is very
smart because it smells the cheese so
the way these kids even build mental
models and think about this it really
reflects the way their parents talk
about these things and think about these
things and they older they get the more
they copy their parents even if they had
robotics workshops or coding workshops
and you're gonna say of course the funny
on what you're telling me is not a
surprise of course parents influence
their kids right yes they do and that's
why we show that it's important not only
to teach kids but also to teach parents
because if a parent would say like oh
yeah Alexa no oh it's intelligent or
like it's smart its artificial
intelligence or if they would actually
encourage the kid like why do you think
it says that how can you probe that how
can we test this is this true right so
we need to have like a
learning culture for the entire family
an AI literacy for the entire family not
only the kids and the other thing that
we see from this study is also the
importance of starting very early the
younger the kids are the more open they
are to consider many different scenarios
and the more prime they are to develop
more critical understanding of this
technology and I would also tell you
that I discover things that really kind
of like blew my mind like I had a lot of
four and five year olds that had seen
multiple robots but had never seen a
mouse they were asked asking me if the
mouse in the video was a robot right and
then another thing we see is again we
need a lot of new words like we need a
new epistemology the fact that people
when they talk about emergent
intelligence and emergent behavior they
they say ok it's smart because it's
programmed and when they say that they
refer to an algorithm or some sort of
capacity of the robot of recording
what's happening or they say it's
programmed then it's stupid it's the
same word but they refer to oh it just
received some simple instructions but it
doesn't know how to apply those
instructions in a different environment
so you can see that when people talk
about AI they say programmed when they
talk about simple coding they say
programmed so we need new words to
actually start to think about at which
point a simple learning mechanisms of
detecting edges and colors become
something more than that at which point
we get this Gestalt phenomenon right so
we there's a lot of work to do and
basically this is this is the part about
the the new words and you can see some
quotes from from the kids and the
parents and and then the the next study
and this is a I'm not gonna bore you
with too much research or although
that's what I do I also code I'm going
to show you some code as well but
because I told you about my friend Kayla
right and how it got banned in Germany
you're gonna say okay they think it's
smart that's great but how much can
these devices actually influence kids
and I'm gonna tell you that the answer
is a lot so we did another study where
it was a conformity study how many of
you have heard about the marshmallow
study yeah so the marshmallow study was
the study where you would want to see if
the child would actually be able to
self-control and not pick up a
marshmallow if the researcher would
leave the room I'm overly simplifying it
but basically in in this study we tried
to do a disobedience task and see if the
doll could convince the child to open a
box and then we did a conformity test
where the child will actually watch
videos that were saying is it okay or
not okay to heat another child is it
okay or not okay to stand when everyone
is sitting and then they would play a
game and then the we would bring the
doll and the doll would try to change
the answers for the kids and the doll
would say I think it's okay I think it's
not okay and then we measured how much
the kids change their answers
so we had three conditions one condition
where the kids were with the doll one
condition where they were with the
Confederate which is another person and
one condition which was the control
condition where they were alone in just
watching the video two times and what we
found is that in terms of moral
questions the doll would be more
efficient at changing children's mind
than a human Confederate so a child
could actually when prompted by the doll
we change more his questions in to two
morality questions like is it okay or
not okay to hit another child then he
would do in front of a human now of
course this is just a pilot study and
we're actually doing follow-up studies
but and there's many reasons for why
that could happen right maybe they were
just trying to prompt they were trying
to test the doll and see how would the
doll react or maybe they were just
playing or maybe they were less afraid
to change their mind in front of a doll
than in front of an adult right either
in any of those scenarios this shows
that children can actually be influenced
by these devices right you can imagine a
scenario where someone like
your likes our smart doll and tells your
child to buy things or go induce things
how do we know how do we make sure as
developers as parents as you know civil
engage members of the society that this
will not happen right and how do we
prepare kids to know what is okay and
what is not okay from a smart device to
ask from them so basically what I'm
trying to say is that I think a
connected family should not look like
this right how many times if you travel
a lot like I do on planes you see this
and even at home right we are a
connected we're so connected now that we
don't even know how to do more simple
things like playing and talking to each
other we need to design technology to
help us go back to something that was so
natural before so I want families to
look more like this where it's not just
the kids who are learning how to code
and learning how to tinker with AI but
it's also parents who are supporting
them and doing it together and for doing
that I created this platform that I call
cockney mates it's like a learning
companion so the idea is that you're
learning AI by making and by coding and
my first first extension was by using
this like open-source robot it's called
ergo it's done by NA VI group in France
and I build an extension for it and I'm
gonna show you what you can do with it
it's using scratch blocks to program it
but then you can also train it motions
so you can teach it how to draw
something
and then you will replay the motion
you're shown it so it's kind of like
learning by demonstration it also makes
mistakes she's very cute or training to
act happy or behave like a dog and
because it's really printed we can
change the heads or change its
configurations but then over time we can
start to teach it more complicated
things like how to play games with us
like rock-paper-scissors or throw
objects or collaborate with other robots
yeah kids have a blast this is their
favorite activity the ball throwing and
so on and then after the Ergo robot I
start developing a similar interface so
all of the programming interface is
using visual blocks so it's a visual
blocks language based on block Li which
is open source and scratch which was
also developed at Media Lab so the next
extension was for G Bo which is another
social robot and I really like this
example because again going back to the
idea of play and tinkering this is a
girl who is seven her name is Tiana and
she never programmed before and then I
showed her G bow which is the social
robot and then the first initial version
of the platform I built and then she
made this game which was like very
simple in terms of code and there's
actually a mistake there there's also a
forever loop B so it happens all the
time so basically the robot has the
attention on which means it's always
tracking like sounds and motion and if
it sees more than one person he would
say I see you and Tiana made this game
to play hide and seek with the robot but
she played for half an hour right so
these are the type of projects that lead
to very rich learning experiences where
the code is very readable anyone can
understand it and remix it and change it
but the playfully interaction is very
rich and we don't have kids only sitting
in front of computers but we actually
have kids playing with this device
in the real world so the good thing
about having this kind of like social
robots and embodied intelligent agents
is that they can also play a role in the
learning process so imagine there's no
teacher parent or mentor that has the
time to be there with a child the robot
itself can play an active role when it's
being programmed and it can tell you if
you did the right thing or not or how
you could do things differently and that
looks like this so this is giba trying
to teach us how to teach him here our
name no I need you to help me ask a
question that will need the s-block
see if you can find it
awesome he's encouraging us when we're
doing the right thing or like prompting
us to do something else when we're like
not using a loop for example or could do
could refactor our code and and what's
cool about this kind of interaction is
that we see a lot of collaboration so we
see kids programming with four hands
under the table one of them is touching
the robot another one is going and
changing the code and and that's what we
want to see we want to see like and also
we bring parents in right so we want to
see and then the parents don't dare to
go to the computer so we give them a
tablet so you can actually program Gebo
from multiple devices at the same time
so they're like oh look what I did and
look what I did so they're like starting
to share these experiences and from
those initial like prototypes with Ergo
and G ballcock teammates is now online
you can play with it it's open source
and it's free it's cockney made semi and
we have many many more extensions so
anything from programming your lecture
to programming micro bit but if you
don't have any hardware there's a lot of
things that you could do just in the
browser on a phone or in a tablet it
looks like this it has one part where
you have the visual blocks that I was
telling you about
then in the middle there's the coding
area where we put the blocks together
and then on the right side we see the
stage so it's the output of what we're
doing and if it's physical then the
output would be in the physical world
and these are a couple of examples of
extensions so the extension we built for
Alexa calls mom which is another smart
toy Gebo but then there's a lot of
extensions with it for cognitive
services like detecting feelings from
text or sensing colors or getting image
classification results so we wanted to
provide kids off-the-shelf AI api's but
then we also wanted them to train their
own and I'm gonna show you that in a in
a second so how do you build such an
extension so usually you find like a
useful and interesting API and then you
define okay what kind of blocks with a
child need what are the primitives then
we're gonna write functions for what
those blocks are doing and then we're
testing it in the browser but before
doing that you need to come up with a
cool idea and usually that comes from
kids like stuff like controlling robots
in the water with your mind which is
actually something we did right so we
made an extension for the muse headset
and then like for the Lego we do and
then with the cocky mates you can
actually connect them together so for
the API you or like node modules we were
just requiring that you can see here the
the sentiment variable which is
requiring that known module it's using
the F in data database for for sentiment
analysis and then the way we define
blocks this is all JavaScript um the way
we define blocks is we have different
types we can make a block be a hat which
is the block that executes code after
that or a reporter or a command block
and then these blocks are calling a
function and then we just define a
JavaScript function which will go to my
API and pass the text I'm typing in the
block and say what kind of score is this
text if it's more than a specific
threshold is it's going to be positive
if it's less it's going to be negative
or else neutral it's extremely simple
this is one of the most simple
extensions it's 90 lines of code all of
our code is on github if you search
coffee mates on github you're gonna see
it and then basically what you see from
a child perspective are blocks like this
and again the language matters a lot and
this is where we iterated a lot with
kids because it turns out that the kids
that I'm working with 7 to 12 know what
a feeling is but don't know what a
sentiment is right so we had to change
sentiment to feeling and then we
realized that they really like questions
so instead of having a block that says
get the feeling of text it's much better
to put a block like what is the feeling
of the text right so in this case we
actually have like a character that is
reacting to the sentiment of what
messages were giving to it to it and if
we have more than that character if we
have Jibo we can make Gebo react to the
sentiment of messages we're giving to it
this is Tiana showing how explain to me
what you're doing I'm running out of
time so I'm gonna like skip through it
the example for the LXi extension I'm
gonna skip through that as well
and I and I told you that after they use
off-the-shelf api's for vision computer
vision or sentiment analysis kids train
their own models so we're using IBM
Watson in the backend so they're only
there's like we're doing transfer
learning they're only training the last
layer so they can build their own
classifiers for text and for images so
we build like interface that is like
really really simple for kids to use
where they can say okay add your
category what do you want to teach the
computer I want to teach the computer to
recognize cats versus dogs or rock
versus paper and then I'm gonna add ten
examples of images and then click on
this teach me and then teach the the
computer how to recognize this it would
give me a model ID that I can use in a
block and then I can program my own game
right so usually the way I scaffold this
when I teach kids is okay if you want to
make your robot react when you're saying
kind messages if you didn't have a
classifier you would only be able to
make it react to specific messages but
if you have a classifier that can
recognize all the kind messages then you
can make it react to everything you say
and this is kind of how it looks like
when kids are training AI and building
classifiers together here they were
trying to build a model to recognize
trains and then they have the most like
fascinating explanations you know or our
ideas it's like how can we yeah it's
gonna learn what the picture are gonna
be and and once they train the model
they want to confuse it so they're like
okay we taught it to differentiate like
dogs from Kirby's what if we put a dog
with sunglasses what would it do
and I'm gonna show you a quick oh yeah
and and then the other thing that is
interesting when they train their own
models and their own classifiers is that
they start to see the nuances right it's
not only good versus bad or black versus
white I actually had kids that wanted to
train a model to recognize backhanded
compliments I didn't even know what that
means
backhanded compliments is when someone
says something nice which is actually
not nice like oh you look so good for
being so tired something like that and
then the kids wanted to have a sassy
chat bot that would recognize these
messages so this is what happens when we
actually allowed them to create the data
and train their own classifiers and then
like they love games so they created a
lot of games that they could play with
the computer or with a different robot
and here's the video where you can see
them explaining it but your children how
a robot sees the world how does it learn
to recognize objects how does it know to
recognize words potato we also allow
them to be able to teach a robot or a
computer I'm gonna give you ten examples
of images and then you're gonna learn
what a gesture is so every interaction
you have with it it's kind of like a
conversation so you are having this
learning companion discarding me that is
learning with you and teaching you at
the same time so we were programming
robots you can serve on paper scissors
you did rock-paper-scissors into the
camera and on shoot you did one of the
motions and the camera did one of the
motions
it's like rock-paper-scissors shoot the
computer gets like better as you play
the game cuz like that we might not know
everything at first but if we keep
trying we get better
everyone has heard about like machine
based learning or artificial
intelligence and where the certain no
questions asked for a lot of the more
tech-savvy parents as like to go for it
technology is gonna be a huge part of
their lives much more so than my life if
it's scary for some people whose AI
technology I totally get it but as a
parent and as a teacher I thought it was
really important because these are
skills that 21st century kids need to
have when they understand this idea of a
feedback loop that the more information
you give to a machine or a robot the
better it becomes you know how smart are
you it really allows them to understand
how machine learning in AI is different
than just coding so I think this is a
very powerful paradigm for children so
they understand that when they have an
Alexa at home or smart assistant
everything they do the way they talk to
it gets fed into the algorithm so the
machine is actually reacting to them
well my dog is young we bought a car and
took apart let's see how it worked so
you teach people that young how these
things that grown-ups mostly program how
it works
so yeah seven-year-old thing that AI are
like the cars of their generation and
it's important to take them apart and
understand how they work and the good
news going back full circle to the
studies I showed you in the beginning is
that after testing this in schools for
six weeks more than three times per week
we saw that kids would actually change
their answers to this question of is it
smarter than me do I trust that we saw
that they became much more skeptical and
of AI technologies but they also
understood much more how and when they
can use it and this is really what I'm
hoping to do with [ __ ] teammates
and I'm going to skip through this
because I actually don't know how much
time I have but um I I basically I
invite you to join me in this in this
adventure and I hope you can contribute
to our open source code I hope you can
contribute to mentor future workshops so
we can have this learning happening for
kids from everywhere right in public
schools in the local community centers
in maker spaces so we can have
collaborative and playful activities
invite everyone our parents and
grandparents and cousins have immersive
creative AI camps you might recognize
some of the people in this picture who
actually came to this camp we did in
Berlin like I think Peter was there
Anagha and you know from leaders like
justin trudeau
too like kids in a church we actually
did workshops in church in a church in
in cambridge with kids that never coded
before we can actually allow kids to be
part of this conversation of how we
shape the future of AI so copy mates is
started just as a research project was
my master thesis project I was kind of
surprised that there's people like
playing with it and testing it all all
over the world and yeah I I hope you
will check out the code there's lots of
bugs to fix or discover in your work
right good API documentation and specs
so we can make expansions and we can
make this kind of tools that make your
work available to a non-technical
audience mentor the generation that
comes after and play right because
that's what it's all about
so yeah this is this is not just my work
this is my team not everyone is there
there's two more people I was joining
this crazy adventure by five MIT
undergrads which were phenomenal and
there are 18 by the way so you can
really do this work at any age and thank
you for your attention and I'll be
around if you guys want to play with
cocky mates or have more questions later
thank you very much
we have time for questions yes one
question one question yes thanks for I
really enjoyed the talk I have one
question regarding the interaction
between between parents and the kids in
this program so imagine that the parent
works in AI or software development that
parent has their different
conceptualization of the entire field do
you did you notice any difficult
difficulties in communication between
parents and their kids regarding all the
interact with robots if the kids learn
better with the different
conceptualization than to what the
parents are using explain them what are
the difficulties with people from tech
teaching their kids yeah thank you for
the question so the question was if I
mean you guys heard it but like I would
say the hardest part of my work and this
kind of work in general is dealing with
parents parents and teachers my mom is a
teacher for primary school it's like for
adults it's much harder to be in a
growth mindset where you're not that
there's only one way or this is the
right way or oh if you didn't use the
correct terms you don't know what you're
talking about right and be more playful
and Socratic and understand how much
we're learning with our natural
intuition and by playing and by
experimenting and maybe I have the wrong
term and the wrong concept but if I'm
poking enough with what I'm doing I will
figure that out right so the important
thing in working with parents is to get
them excited so they become kids again
and you probably saw in the videos at
some point there was one of the parents
and he was doing stuff and the child was
doing stuff you guys were smiling over
here so very often like it turns out the
playing is like riding a bicycle
we never forget it we just need to
remember it so I would say as soon as I
get the parents who go into the child
mode and start playing again it doesn't
matter what field they're working in it
is sometimes harder if the parent comes
with a I'm gonna teach you lecture
mentality instead of oh let's figure
this out but it turns out that this is
so new so even if the parent is working
in AI maybe it hasn't played he hasn't
played would cause more like sign that
way or so it's it's the the experience
is like engaging and interactive enough
for people to play together but there is
a lot of work to be done in terms of
mindset right and leaving room for kids
I talk to kids and treat kids like
adults even if it's a seven-year-old and
they feel that like that's a part of a
presentation I skipped which is the
co.design it's like if you take them
seriously and you really listen to what
they have to say and their ideas and I
showed them like I changed a platform
based on what you're telling me right
you want this block we're gonna build
this block you want to change this we're
gonna change this you want the character
to be scary we're gonna make it scary
right so it's like if you leave room and
actually let the kids teach us because
they see things and they have ideas that
we don't anymore because we are like you
know we're in our path then I think a
lot of magic can happen so I don't know
if I answer your question it's hard to
work with parents but I'm trying thanks
it's a matter of curiosity right yes at
any age yes thank you so much to fine
you for your talk Thanks great well
about please
[Applause]